Some video games are fun from start to finish.
Others seem to leave out the "finish" part
and remain unbeatable forever. Here's a selection
of games that, for whatever reason, haven't
been beaten by very many people. Maybe you'd
like to try?
Battletoads
Its difficulty is the stuff of myth. Many
claim to have beaten Battletoads without having
any actual proof. The adventures of Rash,
Zitz, and Pimple were exceptionally challenging
because you had to battle multiple streams
of bad guys, and you could accidentally punch
your own teammate. It was completely possible
to keep dying because of friendly attacks.
Harsh.
Takeshi's Challenge
Takeshi's Challenge gave fits to Japanese
Famicom fans. The "Takeshi" in question is
actor/director Takeshi Kitano, a man who holds
the distinction of being one of the first
celebrities to get involved with the world
of gaming. Sadly, his efforts produced what
is wildly considered to be one of the worst
games of all time. Takeshi's Challenge is
nearly unbeatable, largely because of gameplay
that pretty much depends on trial and error.
There's even one section that requires the
use of the second controller's microphone
to sing karaoke. While the game could be beaten
by suffering through the confusing gameplay,
you could have also thrown 30,720 punches
on the opening screen to get to the ending.
Say goodbye to your thumbs. And maybe your
mind.
Super Meat Boy
Released in 2010, Super Meat Boy was created
as an intentional throwback to the crazy-hard
games of our youth. And if you ask anyone
who's played it, it definitely delivers on
that promise. There are tons of videos on
YouTube that show players dying over, and
over, and over again. Needless to say, Super
Meat Boy is one of the hardest games released
in recent memory, and fans love it for that
very reason. And while there are plenty of
players that soldiered through the challenge
of beating the game, Steam's Global Gameplay
stats list a measly two percent of players
have achieved 100 percent completion on it.
Maybe they should rename this game "Super
Incomplete Boy."
Friday the 13th
As we mentioned, Super Meat Boy is an homage
to the tight, challenging games of yesteryear.
But for every Metroid or Super Mario Bros.,
there are lots of other old games that were
hard not because they were good, but because
they were bad. Very, very bad. Case in point:
Friday the 13th for the original Nintendo
Entertainment System. In 2009, Game Informer
magazine included this on its list of the
worst horror video games. Other magazines
have gone a step further by calling Friday
the 13th one of the worst games ever made,
period. Friday the 13th is very nearly impossible
to beat...but mostly because it's so crappy
that most players would simply throw their
controllers through the TV before getting
anywhere close to completing it.
That still counts, right?
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
Konami's Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles game
deserves a special place on our list. Despite
the fact that it gave players bald spots from
tearing their hair out in frustration, it
was actually very popular at the time. Because
of impossible experiences like the ones provided
by Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles, we can fondly
look back on a time when games not only challenged
us, but also extinguished our hope of finishing
them. Call it a sneak peek at the harsh realities
of adult life.
"Ooohhhhh noooo!"
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know which game you think is unbeatable...